in February in Charlottesville Virginia
the City Council voted to remove a 93
year old statue of Confederate Civil War
general robert e lee from a public park
then they also voted to rename the park
which is currently called lee park the
Confederate General we've actually seen
this across the country right changing
the names of schools named after racists
changing street names and removing
statues we've seen this trend in the
u.s. over the last few years
Charlottesville is best known for being
the home of the University of Virginia
and I believe this was a good move by
the City Council this is the 21st
century we've been talking on the show
lately ever since Donald Trump's
ignorant and confused statements about
the Civil War we've been talking about
how many people in the south have been
to put it charitably slow to acknowledge
that the Civil War was fought over
slavery and that glorifying and
eulogizing the Confederacy is sort of
affirming slavery and racism whether
people want to admit it or not now
remembering history and educating people
about the past in history books and in
museums that's one thing and I am
obviously in favor of that but
celebrating and sort of fondly
remembering the Confederacy is ignorant
and it disrespectful to say the least
the statue is still scheduled to be
removed it hasn't been removed yet so
Saturday night in Charlottesville in the
park where this statue has been for many
years a flock of dozens of neo-nazis
white nationalist racist members of the
all right call him whatever you want
they gathered around the statue to
protest the removal of the statue and
they were holding torches to add another
wrinkle to the story the protest was led
by none other than Richard Spencer the
white separatist white supremacist sort
of neo-nazi guy who coined the term all
right we recently actually interviewed
him on the program the swarm of people
at the park were chanting Nazi slogans
about ethnic purity and also and this is
just
weird chanting Russia is our friend
here's the even more hilarious part
these folks would love for you to think
of them as these hardcore outlaw
activists that are willing to push the
envelope and do anything for their cause
10 minutes after their small protest
started the cops showed up told them put
your torches away and go home and they
immediately did so the police scared
them so they just gave up and left and
of course the counter would be well
these are law-abiding citizens but the
entire thing was just bizarre when you
saw the way it went down Charlottesville
mayor marks ignor setting a statement
quote this event involving torches at
night in Lee Park was either profoundly
ignorant or designed to instill fear in
our minority populations in a way that
harkens back to the days of the KKK
reality is that it was sort of both
right I mean the demonstration was
ignorant and intended to be racist and
I'm glad that it stopped after not very
long but these guys wanted to instill
fear although I guess you could say they
failed they were trying to be dramatic
with the tortures but then they put the
torches out and left the scene as soon
as the cops showed up
what kind of revolutionaries are they
claiming to be this this must have been
immensely embarrassing for them and the
torches seem kind of silly in a way just
kind of met for theatrics this is what a
torch looks like for people who are
watching on TV or on YouTube with us and
from what I can tell by this photo it
looks like a lot of them are kind of
holding those key key candles that
people put in their backyard does very
very strange optics around the entire
thing